[Musique]
ce monde autour de nous on ne l'a pas
choisi ils nous ont divisés ils ont fait
de nous des pantins sans vie sans espoir
mais aujourd'hui tout va changer
bienvenue dans le camp expérimental de
roald ces derniers seuls les meilleurs
seront retenus
intégrer la plus haute caste
alphanumériques
vous allez être soumis à une série de
tests physiques et psychologiques de
haute intensité
un émetteur vous sera implanté afin de
vous localiser à tout moment
[Musique]
nous avons repéré un groupe de
clandestins omega ils ont quitté leur
zone de confinement prestations
demandées
j'étais venu avec elle tu enfreint la
loi
pas un mot non par la personne ce que tu
éprouves est interdite ils vont vous
traquez cachant d'où viens avec moi mais
où veux tu aller dans un endroit où nous
serons libres à cette fille est une
omega une heure la loi et doit aussi
maintenant il va
[Musique]
ils n'auront aucune pitié
on trouvera un moyen de s'enfuir avec
var
dans le monde que nous avons bâti
personne ne peut s'enfuir